but they felt like
rocks i mean like not
you know not guns and roses e rock stars
not like you know nirvana rockstars they
were like people we knew in bands not
people other people knew and certainly
not people susan sarandon would know
about like what is happening like it
just seemed crazy that there would be
any
it seemed like things from two different
worlds
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
this holiday season i'm giving thanks to
our friends at manscape do i tell my
extended family that i have the
performance package four row from the
global leaders in below the waist
grooming
not to mention it includes their
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer to tame my bush
and score brownie points with the
in-laws
get yourself manscaped for the man in
your life
who needs it join the two million men
worldwide who trust manscape with 20 off
and free shipping with this code
l-m-g-h-i
by going to
manscape.com not only will i thank you
but i can speak for your webos and
they're gonna thank you as well be
thankful this holiday season for the
best gift of all from manscape the balls
will thank you are you the left ball or
the right ball
both balls
you know what is there real life anymore
i you know what i'm going to say that
that there is you know there's portions
of our life that aren't real
when people are holding phones up
at you know gene simmons i'm a big rock
you know big rock guy uh first concert
kiss last concert was
uh
but
you know they come down on those
platforms and he almost gene simmons
almost like ate it and it's uh
everybody had it on their phone as the
camera was show as the camera that films
all their shows you see a thousand
people all capturing it on a camera
and um
you know it loses its impact of you
watching a car accident of like not
being involved i think i think bobcat
goldthwait said about the rodney king
video
at the first comic release or one of the
comic releases like put that [ __ ]
camera down help me
we're all witnessing everything through
this like second lens all the time of
yeah it's crazy um so maybe maybe real
life already ceased to exist before
covid but it's extra
um
extra that way now you know um
i don't know how you spend your days but
you know i used to see somebody that
from the time they woke up or on their
phone
checking their facebook i guess like
people read the paper but it just seems
more
disconnected when somebody's looking at
a phone as opposed to i mean a mole but
turning up if you saw somebody reading
the paper you didn't want to bother them
because they were reading the paper
but now yeah that's so true that there's
like this sort of respect for where your
attention is that we used to have that
now is just like completely over it's
like
you're i mean if you're on your phone
then you're supposed to also be having a
conversation with someone and like
driving your car
you know like you'll see people in new
york all the time like smack into each
other you know like walking down the
street with the thing out and then just
wham like crash into someone else and
it's like not even weird nobody's
embarrassed it's like oh sorry and then
you just move right along there was a
stage in your matrix there was there was
a woman we went to barnes one one night
and um this guy alex i used to drive me
and there was a girl that had the
cupping marks on her back
you know from doing cupping near these
bruises and i said does that work
cupping and she looks at me she goes
don't talk to me please can i just shop
don't talk to me
don't be walking around with [ __ ] cup
marks on your back
i don't know i just think it's just that
reaction but maybe it wasn't my business
to say does that work like i'm invading
you know what do we do excuse me can i
ask you a question no okay
but but um i think it's a bit of an
advertisement to have a conversation if
you're walking or as someone who has
done cupping before like there's such a
thing as a sweater you know so if you
really don't want anyone to ask you any
questions about the massive bruises on
your back you could certainly do
something about that you know it's like
celebrities that go to um really
paparazzi restaurants and then complain
about being bothered by paparazzi i mean
there's a little bit of a kind of
invitation to
to talk to me element um
that's my thesis you know well listen
i'm not saying this to but i used to go
to school with bruises on my back uh
almost every week and i would take my
shirt off in front of the teachers and
none of them said a word so god bless
them over there
elementary school keeping my
hidden punishment a cupping
but but uh yeah you know i find i find
um
you know i find music fascinating and
i'm an only child and i didn't really
wasn't musical you know i've been trying
to play the guitar forever but
music
you know it has a play vietnam gill went
to vietnam
so much of the music of the movies of of
war movies are the movie the music of
vietnam sure um apocalypse now and you
know lawrence fishburn i think he was 13
and he's on the gun boat and they're
playing
something for the devil or something and
it's just
everything kind of
puts the music in in the place of your
life even you know
things that you can
go to and remember seeing when i was in
new york there was a place called the
crime scene across the street from
cbgb's and when i got out of the cab the
guy said i said hey man that's cbgb's
and he was like yeah they're getting
ready to turn it into a barbados get the
[ __ ] out of here another night and he
goes yeah uh hilly's in there and i said
oh [ __ ] i said you never been in there i
went in there and hilly was there
and
i
it's true you know he couldn't get
hillary away from me but but
he wanted me to help him not turn into a
barbados i said hey i don't know if i
had like i'm just on abc at that time
but but to go in there
and to see where all of these bands
started you know blondie and
lou reed and the ramones and
and is that your music like is that
stuff that means something to you
soundtrack of your lifestyle not you
know
i would say not entirely but i'm
it the range is so broad that it did
mean something to you know if i went to
uh london i would probably go to the to
the um
is it called the caravan or the thing
wherever the down below place where the
beach the cabin club
yeah yeah so so um i think uh and gill's
got his oldies you know he that's all i
listen to yeah that's all he listens to
what do you listen to gil what's your
stuff i like music from the 60s 60s
early 70s let's say with those things
and fifties
what's your cut off what's like the cut
off band where you're like no more
that's as far as we go into music
history uh there's the little tower of
power i picked up later
uh
wasn't oldies but they play they've been
around a long time they play a lot of rb
stuff so i love tower of power
earth wind and fire i'll go with them
santana uh his stuff uh
and then i'm back to what i did
predictable
we take a 25-year jump into sierra
what about uh sliding the family stone
out of the bay area
stones
they were big when i was in vietnam they
were big you know how great sliding the
family stone like the clash
if you look at
there's no guitar chord
manual for the
it's like if you can't play the guitar
don't don't because there is no chord
it's just that that that
that
yeah they're just that little stupid
people and uh rock the cast bar if you
look up how to play rock the cast ball
there's no the dude's like i think it's
kind of like this they don't have a
guitar
they're like we don't know how to play
them
it's just so kind of simple but you know
blitzkrieg bopped
three little places and i've been in an
immortal
iconic
uh i love blitzkrieg uh a song yes so
let's let's get you know it's like that
thing too where it's innovation can be
so simple i mean i think the best music
that we care about you just named a lot
of it it's like
i always say this as a music critic and
someone who's written about music for a
long time it's like i know there's
something good it's something new that
i'm hearing that's good if it feels
familiar like if there's a part of me
that's like hang on have i heard this
before in some way and not in a bad way
like it's repetitive but more like it's
already
feels like part of
music history there's a sort of
obviousness to it and i think people are
really afraid you know there there's
often this desire to over complicate art
in a lot of ways but like music is the
ultimate level for that because you're
just like
does it sound good or not does it make
me feel something or not it's like not
intellectual in that way um and it can
be very simple deceptively simple
to your point you know
how are we even playing these songs but
i really didn't appreciate
uh when i was younger the beatles the
beach boys i didn't like to hear them at
all
now
i understand music and i loved their
music they were so complicated so good
so well put together they were genius
yeah
imagine totally imagine when you would
go to a hard rock cafe or go to
a museum or go to some place that were
collectors and they had
lucy in the sky with diamonds written on
a notebook pad or purple haze
that jimi hendrix wrote out himself and
crossed out
different words and put words in there
and that's what we had we don't we don't
we don't have we won't have that anymore
you know nobody
which you know a lot of screenshots of
like a notes app yeah iphone totally
it doesn't really have the same romance
to it does it i guess you could like
print it out and frame it or something
so
do how does your
where does your love of music come from
and then where does the love of
finding the history of it and finding
the people of it come from and before
you answer should i do the intro here
i'm going to introduce her you know what
you know i had a bunch of shows and a
lot of the [ __ ] was intros and stuff
but but
yeah ron should just spoil the moment
for the listeners um so today on the
podcast joining us is uh lizzie goodman
she's an author she's a rock and roll
journalist
author of the book meet me in the
bathroom which is an oral history of
music in new york from 2001 to 2011 and
i'm just reading a blurb here so tell me
if this is true also have an upcoming
memoir called all my friends love loss
and rock and roll in new york city i
love that i mean if i even end up
writing it that will be true it's really
easy to say it's true when you haven't
written it yet so like yeah let's go
with that um but yes that's me um
thank you for that beautiful
introduction yeah thank you and you know
now we're all like we lost our pedals on
our bike
just jump back into the stream of things
but i find you and i think deal will too
uh um
very interesting because
it's something that i think as we reach
back
to something that 2001 to 2010 even
doesn't seem like a long time but a lot
has changed in that in that in that time
um no it's crazy yeah who loves music
yeah
sorry i'm sorry who loved music in your
family did everybody yes i was just
gonna say everything you guys are saying
about the music you grew up on i mean i
think one of the funniest things i was
just talking to my parents about this
because i recently moved home i'm from
new mexico originally and now i'm living
back here from
i lived in new york for a long time
obviously and i also lived in la for a
bit and now i'm back in new mexico and
it's great and i've been talking to my
parents
you know they live here still so i'm
seeing them a lot more and i was saying
to my dad the other day i was like okay
because he was a big music guy growing
up and he
did a radio show on the local like kind
of public radio station and it was often
you know he's your dad so you're just
like oh dad music like he was really
into folk music and all this stuff that
my brother and i weren't into but there
was a lot of good music around the house
too the beatles rolling stones dylan all
that and
hilariously
they missed all of the 70s my parents
like it was all 50s and 60s music there
was no 70s music there was like a couple
of dylan 80s albums which is you know
not a key moment for dylan in a lot of
ways and then um
but randomly they were into the talking
heads okay and i said to my dad at
dinner the other night i was just like
seriously now that i understand the sort
of context of music history where the
[ __ ] did that come from like how did you
end up being interested in it was like
you know
folky dylan records and then burning
down the house so um
and his answer was
the like stopped making sense and the
sort of film work that
had that had been done that david byrne
had done kind of they saw those movies
randomly and that like got them
interested in the talking heads and so
they bought that wreck those records and
or maybe like one talking heads record
and not even their best and that was
also cycled into the rotation of the
goodman family um listening world so but
that's like it's an example of how music
is so personal that way right like if
you're studying it
you start in one place you kind of
dutifully investigate all this stuff but
that's not really how we consume music
it's so visceral and so much a part of
our like lived experience like you hear
a song on the radio in a moment in your
life that matters and that becomes
important to you or your
your dad plays something and
it feels it all feels part of the same
like box in your head like for me
growing up the beatles and and the
talking heads were just that was dad
music they were the same you know it's
like crazy so it all comes around you
know
i needed a uh
fine arts class to get my bachelor's
and so i took music appreciation that's
when a guy was just trying to get out of
school
i needed a class i needed to find out
that he wanted me to i didn't learn
but i took music appreciation
and this very elderly professor was up
there talking to us about music
appreciation and she was going to
play some of the first
written music
in history
and she started playing it and i started
laughing
i started chuckling i did and she
stopped the music she said excuse me mr
career was something funny
about the music we're playing i said no
but i finally realized this was music
that they play when the pope is being
elected
it's gregorian chant now there's a name
put to it
and i thought this was funny it was all
bringing it back
and she says oh well i applied that's
good you're right this is gregorian
chant now that you've said
and everything went well so it does
bring back
and i was just looking for an easy class
you learned yeah you learned something
that first day
but it took um
for my science requirement in college i
took astronomy because i was like it'll
be i think this is a very common
trying to get out of science mistake
that people make astronomy is so hard
it's just 100 math i was like
we're gonna go look at the stars and
like there's gonna be you know i don't
know it'll be this sort of romantic
experience and really it was just
equations all day long and i was like oh
no
how am i going to get out of it you know
you would look up to the sky
you would look up to the sky for solace
not for
[ __ ] mathematics
that you can't figure out and the
galileo and the stars are always the
same and they can lead you
and pull you out of out of things that i
just don't look up this you were you are
teaching you were beginning to teach the
class i was expecting and unfortunately
that's not what i found i wanted you
know i wanted all the stuff you just
said you know what i was around when my
father used to
[Laughter]
you walk up there and go [ __ ] i gotta
get going man
now i have a burning question what part
of new mexico are you from
i'm from a burning question outside of
albuquerque outside of albuquerque
my relatives are all from gallup i used
to go there every year i'll be back
there soon and they
once they once they get socialized then
they move from gallup to albuquerque
i think they're getting fostered that's
crazy so you know gout wow yeah oh yes i
do very well
it's the the new mexico thing is special
and weird and only people who've really
spent time here most of the time you
hear that if you have family here you
know it's like people will just be like
yeah i drove through there once yeah
i'll hear that all okay here's the
question yes that's where i'm from did
you take any dirt did you take any dirt
with you when you went to new york
i think it's magical dirt up
in my only thing honestly yes i used to
get told
by my ex he would be like back in new
york in the sort of era that the book i
wrote covers
i guess if i was just getting too
annoying or something he would just or
just too stressed he would be like
you need to go home
it's time for you to go do whatever it
is you do there like talk to the dirt
commune with the whatever like it's
enough i can't deal with you get on a
plane when you come back we'll be able
to have this conversation sort of a
dirt cleansing from the magical
magical land here but no it's really
it's beautiful and cool and
um
i don't know it's like a good place to
be creative um
i was going to actually actually ask you
george like
what's your day you said earlier you
know you don't know how i what how do i
spend my days in newspaper reading and
all these things we used to do what do
you do first thing in the morning like
what's your routine
that well
yes george very good question no no
listen i i i'm i think you know stop
making sense i think all those
documentaries you know when
documentaries are maybe and books on
tape and and everything now
are
what people enjoy you know when they
walk the podcast now you know and things
like that but i um
it's funny because i'm i'm a music
person
on youtube and a real crime person so
gill
even though his last
i think one of the theaters uh together
was the last
song
that's it he listened to but but but a
lot of latino a lot of chicano singers
so i like i like that but also i like
the crime aspect of of true crime i
don't know i i was not a criminal grown
up i knew guys that uh were
and they were so casual about one one of
my friends was uh
stature limitations on murder i might be
telling the wrong person i don't think
there is there is no education
but a gentleman that i heard you go on
i said yeah i mean
you know i'm kind of gravitated to the
things that
i was afraid of you know i tried been
trying to play guitar forever
i grew up you know
idolizing these guys most of the guys i
grew up idolizing i'm friends with in a
in a crazy way but also crime and
documentaries and
and those things you know it's funny
gill's a detective like when i was a kid
i i used to drag net and san francisco
and and i thought about you know every
kid dreams about being somebody i'd have
been a detective i would have
would have liked to have been a
detective
do you like asking people questions i
mean clearly you're hosting a podcast so
yes but you know there's that like
being inquisitive about other people's
lives and that can go and i'm obsessed
with true crime too and and also just
like thriller
like right like elmore leonard or any
any sort of
all those like noir detective fiction
stuff because i think it's really
related to the idea for me it's i'm a
journalist of just being honestly kind
of
nosy
that's a personality type like no
complaint just wanting to know stuff i
had no idea how much yeah i had no idea
how much people were in the true crime
because that was i did that for a living
until this last year i went up to austin
to a crime con
i was a speaker up there and people from
all walks of life up there especially
these people that are following
crimes now they want to solve them they
want to do this and they're very
enthusiastic about it and i was really
surprised being on the podcast
of how knowledgeable george is
on a lot of these old major crimes uh
serial killers it's incredible
really
yeah this is your secret look he's
smiling
it's just that so that's a proud moment
i have such a lonely life i just enjoy
other people
taking the initiative no i i mean
take
but but but i do you know i i i um
i'm not as public as i i don't know i i
just think that's how things find you
you know you find things that you know
if it wasn't for this damn apple tv the
minute i have apple tv i stopped really
engaging with people
i mean it wasn't isn't that the
beginning of the end like i became a
buddhist they were always around me i
could have lived with just saying oh
those dudes i grew up around those guys
instead of seeing the documentary on the
dalai lama and then going to boston and
then meeting them and then all of a
sudden now but but you know up until
2007 i was just happy with saying oh
monks yeah i grew up every every kind of
place i lived near had monks around
never thought it was a sign
but but now
it's made me it's made me a different
person now i don't want to
be harmful to other people i just watch
other people who are harmful
it's a vicarious like you know uh
methadone
the two things that survive i think you
know oxygen uh the channel
it has oxygen true crime channel
uh
the learning channel which nobody wanted
to watch put [ __ ] shelves together
has become like a crime the learning
channel and everything is is taking is
taking crime but also
what's great about and mayan of course
you know introduced me to youtube is all
of every aspect and dimension and look
at
rock music is explored and music
explored they'll say
you know dede ramone's last interview
and you're like oh dedi ramone's last
interview i wouldn't have found that
anywhere else so i so i'm not sure that
people that are are younger than us will
ever appreciate the music that we listen
to nor do i think it's fair to say that
the music that is being created
right now
we'll never really have a dialogue about
i think you know but that's how it's
supposed to be right i mean there is
this whole argument that it's definitely
gotten it's definitely different in a
post-internet world i'm not saying it's
not obviously it would be a really
stupid argument to make that claim but
it's also always been true that you
don't understand for the most part the
next generation's music in the same way
you understand your own and vice versa
and like your parents or people slightly
older than you aren't supposed to it's
not that like period of youth where
you're discovering your stuff it's so
uh personal and specific and there's
also all these like brain development
things we understand now about what's
happening to your mind when you're in
your 20s and how it's not fully formed
yet and so the music that gets in during
that time does literally have a
different impact on someone who's 20 or
21 22 than it does on someone who's 30
31 32. so it's like stage of life and
also all that stuff is i guess i think
you know so much has changed and also so
little has changed because i still don't
yeah i mean now i'm like i listen to i
follow
whatever what people are listening to
what young people are listening to just
because i want to know but it's
different it's like i'm old now i have
no idea why they care about what they
care about but i like to learn but i
don't feel it in the same way
is that true that we get trapped in like
whatever hair you had in high school do
you have now
you heard that like you see people that
i mean listen
i've had a few moments where my eyes
were open i was i at um
i was at the hollywood bowl watching the
who
on this last kind of tour a couple years
ago and there was a guy sitting next to
me with a who's next t-shirt with some
puka shells and some stone wash
jeans and above my age with the same
hair and i looked her over and i said
other than this cool ass top that i got
at barney's in new york i'm [ __ ] just
like this dude like we're living in the
past like i don't think i'm living in
the past
but
i think i think we are i think we are a
bit
nostalgic for
those things totally nostalgia is its
own thing and i think everyone feels it
and now in our in our like warped hyper
speed culture that we're in now it's
like it's it's
more of that and more marketed you know
we're like buying nostalgia more we're
being sold it but i don't know i don't
think it's i maybe i'm just like naive
but i don't think it's i sort of don't
worry about this like i worry about
plenty of things but
you're not living in the past you're
just enjoying your connection to
something that you loved when you were
young and you know enjoying the shared
fashion sense that you guys have carried
on briefly into the new world of
whatever you're trying to join life
yeah
what about when you forget music you
know like my grandmother hated music she
hated everything that i did she really
you know all of the you know i have to
say
yeah she
but but also i have to say in her
defense all of the people that i
followed
richard pryor lit himself on fire
freddie prince killed himself
and bill cosby we all know that but my
grandma was alive she would say hey what
about your hero scout on who
bill cut he's not my hero he's not i
mean everybody that i admired
has fallen by the wayside that that's so
in her defense you're like maybe she was
on to something track record
she hated me watching soul train
she hated american bachelorette so she
wasn't she just hated music i think
which i don't know how some people if
somebody can hate music they got a black
heart man i mean and i went to go see
the temptations three nights in a row
you did where was that this is back in
the uh
late 70s at
oh i saw him at the greek theater i saw
him at
maybe universal amphitheater it was
three three days in a row i went to see
him with oh my god i'm so jealous three
different
one of them yeah one of them was pearl
and the other two were not three
different yeah yeah
they would say it was fun
um
a band was just at the hollywood
palladium and they sold it out and they
were jamming and it made me feel good
that
bands were back in and that the holly
palladium was still a great venue to see
um i don't think it's rock music but
muse it was a music
they're still yeah i mean what's the
last show anyone's seen you know that's
also obviously the industry has been
like pretty roughed up by kovig because
nobody but it's starting again i went to
go see the temptations just for kovitz
struck
there were only two of the originals
left but i went to go see him la merada
and they're going to be
uh what's left of them now is going to
be performing out here in l.a steven
steakhouse
[Laughter]
think your holiday spread is good it's
time to give thanks to the manscape
performance package 4-0 or as i like to
call it the perfect package for your
package inside you'll find their
lawnmower 4-0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your goodies
think of it as a cornucopia for your
balls does it everything that's the way
i think about it yeah can't forget
manscaped liquid formations they're like
pumpkin pie and ice cream after
thanksgiving dinner you can't live
without it the crop preserver
ball deodorant and crop reviver toner
spray your balls will be living in
turkey heaven with these formulations
join the two million men worldwide who
trust manscape with 20 off
and free shipping with this code lmghi
by going to
manscape.com i'm already seeing
werewolves like in the clouds
floating around that's it you see them
i can see them up there with little
wings on them remember guys uh uh balls
used to look like the back of a tv all
wires coming out different
okay now let's get into let's get into
the let's get into the book because i
think i would i'm going to know i'm
going to have to buy it on tape yeah
it's on off tape too i bought it on
audio because that's what i do
i bought it on audio do you do you read
the audio i just want to say in advance
no i don't read it and it's impossible i
mean
i mean no offense to the uh
readers
but
let's just say that it's one of the
things that i think we could have done
better oh because so the book is told
it's an oral history so it's all told in
other people's voices so there's it's
like reading a script there's like 200
characters in it so
there's one female voice that they actor
that they hired and then one male voice
after that they hired right and so it's
a little bit of a rough sell that way
and they and you know what they do that
i listen to enough books on tape well i
listen to the michael jackson uh
be careful who you love and whenever
they get to his part they always say
how do i
you want to know how i deal with my
family
it's the same guy yeah and michael came
into the room and said you see they're
trying to kill me
so yeah we get we get that but yeah you
know
yeah all right
but that's why that's why i think this
is gonna be like you can tell i'm a
terrible sales woman for my own work i'm
like please you know i
like enjoy the audiobook if you like it
i will be thrilled if you like any part
of anything i've ever written that is
always the ultimate goal and thrill so
um well i'm going to read the book then
i'm going to read the book yeah i'll
tell you right now i'm getting on audio
i'm i'm a terrible reader i've never
even read the book on the nightstalker
case
i've never seen that that's because you
wrote them in the knights
you think willie may sat around reading
about himself
[Laughter]
i think he probably do maybe
um i was thinking about the zodiac stuff
too that just came out that they're like
yeah
i wish i were crazy
he's not still alive i mean what is the
latest there yeah give us the latest
well
as an expert obviously um i'm as an
insider to the solving
i mean my expertise on the zodiac
killing is limited to my obsession with
the film like i think that the david
fentrer film is so amazing and i think
it's
because also because it's really hard as
a sort of storyteller to get
i mean
you know
to get an audience to be psyched on a
story that never gets solved is crazy
like you can't that's not how hollywood
works like you're not allowed to not
solve it like what are you talking about
and i think that just the way that he
was able to sort of
tease out the
quiet drama of why we obsess over these
things like it's really a film about
obsession which is what true crime is
like when we're for me at least like as
a consumer of true crime it's like well
what i'm into is
is this sort of place to put my
obsessive tendencies like the obsession
element is like really what's satisfying
about it but i don't know that much
about the recent break in the case
except that they think they they found i
mean they think they've solved it that's
what i understand it's not the first
time they thought they've solved it and
there's
but let's go back let's go back to the
early 70s when this was all happening
kind of on those roads out by the lake
where people used to go
and you know you did i did and you had
people walk up i had people walk up to
cars and and go around and stuff places
that were like you know isolated out of
the way like what happened here but but
to think of the
the mentality of somebody who
writes in code and who has a
a bucket hat kind of with the
with the scope on his face and the whole
thing on the chest
it is
if it wasn't a movie you saw for the
first time you'd be like wow that's some
chilling [ __ ] like silence of the lamp
but this guy was doing that in in real
life that was his own it reminded me of
the btk guy
that was doing it using computers to
tease the cops and writing the newspaper
and killing and torturing his victims
and he did it and then he went dormant
and now he's getting ready to start
again before they caught him right
hmm oh
did what did they say
uh so i was looking it up and it says
that you believe he was a police officer
do you believe he was a police officer
i mean
i don't i don't i i want to find that
hard to believe but i believe that you
know there's that whole like now we live
in a csi world like he's obviously
someone who had a lot of knowledge about
how cops work and what our like
investigative techniques are um so
you know i know it was harder than is
what i'm saying to get all that
information you had to like check out
books from the library and they would
keep there's that famous scene where
they would they know who's reading what
books because of your library card and
all this stuff that feels like very
honestly like quaint now because it's
just like hi we live in a google world
like you're like how do you make a bomb
no problem you just try immediately but
there was like it was so i don't know i
mean of course that's possible but
i don't know
well there's a lot of there's a lot of
people dna closed the book on a lot of
the golden state killer and plus the
golden state killer he was a cop at one
time
so there's
there's precedent to say the cops are
not eliminated from being killers you
know being sociopaths and you did have
some inside knowledge
uh either
[Music]
he had friends did an awful lot of
studying or he was you know what i i
knew some girls that i don't know if you
knew any girls that dated cops i'm not
saying you you've been married over 50
years because there was a girl that was
filipino i still worked during the day
of northridge and she was a filipina
girl she was beautiful and she had an
accent and she was dating the guy from
lapd his name was i shouldn't even say
their name saying their real names his
name was ron
and she
tortured
his name
and
she would make this guy cry man
like she really she would make this dude
start crying and you'd seem like rick
you're crying dude
you're a cop i said you got a uniform on
it's just
we cry why like just just out of his
emotions
yeah yeah like like
he loved her and she
was a little bit you know
out there
and
he couldn't take it and he said you want
me to make rick craig i said no don't
make sure
and cover them up we'd be crying two
minutes later be crying like going out
with my friends and she would go do you
think guys are going to like these
oh my gosh that's awful sounds like a
good thing there's early 80s in
northridge that was around
that time i think i knew her
well cops can't i was gonna say
does this sound familiar no i mean
listen cops can cry you know but it
sounds like she was um you know kind of
mean
meanness knows no bounds i guess
okay i have never dated a cop
or
i mean no i really don't know
or a firefighter although like
i recently was remembering this party
that i had gone to back in new york
where it was like this sort of
firefighter fleet week
somehow i don't remember how i was
connected to this but like a friend of
mine was like this is the weekend where
all the firehouses or whatever have
their
new recruits events and we're gonna go
like troll these bars and like meet cute
firefighter guys and i was like new york
is the greatest town on earth like how
is this possible it's very early in my
tenure there so
i guess that's as close as i've ever
come to you know fulfilling that fantasy
but i guess if um
you know there's it's life is not over
yet we'll see
if i can
there's still time there's still time
but you know those calendars i mean
that's how we got to somebody with a
calendar at the end of the year oh yeah
you know now i mean if you saw the
calendar they'd be like
are you seriously trying to sell
calories i don't know
i think that there's still people that
might want to [ __ ] i had to have been
a money maker we used to walk over to
calendars and look at where is it and
look up at look up adam that's okay
there's a famous sex in the city episode
about this where she goes like she goes
out to i want to say at staten island to
judge this
like
firefighter stripping like chippendales
thing and it's like
there's a you know sort of local
politician there that she ends up dating
and it's all very like they're making
this count it's all very taken very
seriously this goes to show you how much
time has changed in like just a couple
decades like this would be considered
like a very cool thing for whatever
single women in their 30s to be doing in
new york and now we're like guys
remember the dark ages of cough and
firefighter calendar what was that about
anyway uh
yeah i was never at don't look at me i
was never asked to be in the calendar
i was gonna ask i didn't want to put you
on the spot
you know what i might do one of you from
oh my god
okay let let's talk let's talk rock
grant let's talk rock let's talk rock
chuck rock hold on one second i have to
take this toy from my dog that she's
destroying me
let's see your
yeah we're trying to keep her busy i'll
give you a few of my dogs but first i'm
moving this there's three dogs in this
house right now let me see how can i
okay yo you have a picture of your dog
luna
here's let's see let me see is there a
dog let's go that's bill oh
what kind of what kind of dog and then
that is lucinda
[ __ ] bill's out i can't
bill is out and then here's luna she's
under the table where is she there you
go
oh
what a sweet she's beautiful and she's
my mom's dog and she's the troublemaker
shoes i'm like sitting here watching her
slowly demolish this tennis ball and i
think she's spitting all the pieces out
but
you know i don't particularly feel like
going to the emergency vet later today
like i have some other stuff i'd like to
do so um yeah you know yeah there you go
and a very cute beautiful
and he's a stranger
he was a stranger
most of all of mine are refused
fortunately he was a dodger fan
he showed up with that jersey showed up
with that jersey on what kind of dog is
that is that a long-haired it's a uh mix
it's a terrier mix
yeah he's gonna say he looks like you've
got some terrier in him oh
his mother was they're just the best
you know his mother was a what sorry she
was out there a little bit she was out
there she was a [ __ ]
in the streets listen take it easy for
those brothers who were horses she was a
woman of the night she loved me
she loved the evening my mom too my mom
she
yeah
she had itchy feet
i don't think that's a diagnosis
what a place to be one of these days i'm
going to go back to new york not working
on a case i just saw an episode of 30 30
where they showed the athletes from the
new york mets
keith hernandez
doc gooden
uh
strawberry
those guys used to party hard oh yeah
and they talked about go and it showed
them going all their nightclubs and they
had everything they were top of the
world and
all in new york that's the thing about
new york i think that makes it so
special and such a as a sort of um
setting for these for whoever you are
there's like something crazy to be
offered to you by new york city because
it's like every world
music
uh art
like
act acting of course like film and tv
sports business right exactly theater
and everything is happening on top of
itself in all of those worlds all the
time so there's this and it's such a
small place geographically so there's
this way in which whatever your story is
like it's going to be intersecting like
however small and subcultural your world
is and the things you're into it's going
to intersect with just naturally with
some people
from these other worlds and like that's
the magic of the city is that you know
yeah music and and
sports and all these things can collide
um
and do it's pretty amazing it's pretty
amazing uh how did how did you decide to
use those
is it ten years or nine years
for the ten years it's like a decade
yeah how did you decide to pick that
decade of
well i mean it you sort of when you're
trying to make a story out of
a bunch of lived experience that feels
kind of amorphous it helps to kind of
like take a step back and be like
what is the structure here really if i
was asked
if i'm out you sort of pretend to be
interviewing yourself almost like if i
if i knew if i was trying to tell this
story where would i start what would i
say the beginning is and if i was trying
to tell this story what would i say the
ending is and that was kind of helped
along so that created this sort of 10
year block but it was helped along a bit
by the
the day that i had the idea for the book
i was at madison square garden and i had
seen
the strokes play
um a couple nights before and i was
there to see lcd sound system play and
they had they had like sold out all
these dates and
um
for me there's this sort of famous for
me moment of being at lcd sound system
and having seen the strokes a few nights
before and then looking over us on the
floor at madison square garden lcd sound
systems final show allegedly at the time
and over to my right with susan sarandon
and i'm like a massive susan sarandon
fan and it was i was obsessed with the
fact that she was there and like look
there were like lots of cool famous
people at that point around all these
bands that i had known since i was young
like i moved to new york when i was
21 right after college and i knew all
these kids in these bands that i ended
up writing about but they felt like
rocks i mean like not
you know
not guns n roses e rock stars not like
you know nirvani rockstars they were
like people we knew in bands not people
other people knew and certainly not
people susan sarandon would know about
like what is happening like it just
seemed crazy that there would be any
it seemed like things from two different
worlds and so those two shows at those
shows i was like oh
right like what probably was obvious to
many other people for sure at that point
that had not been obvious to me was that
there had been a kind of
time capsule that that those 10 years
marked like the beginning the 911 the
pre and post 9 11 realities for these
bands who all started before then
sort of in one way or another their
reaction creatively to that event in new
york and the way that that shaped
how they how they made music how they
felt about each other like what it felt
like to be in new york during that time
as i'm sure you all know and then
like then an ending of it and not an
ending like oh these vans aren't cool
anymore but then ending in the sense of
susan sarandon is at these shows like
it's not
it's not like me and my friends at some
shitty bar on the lurie side anymore and
so that was kind of the beginning of
thinking about how to make a story of
that and then you know quick seven years
later i published the book
no problem it was really fast
you know the the um
you know michael jackson performed at
madison square gardens that the e the
evening before
let me september 10
2011.
and um
you know things man i mean it's a
20-year anniversary of that and things
did change you know the the idea that
um
[Music]
what this country has has done for all
the families and all the people and the
survivors and all the firemen like
neglected
them
it's a very very sad thing man i mean
if you go even now if you go
by the veterans hospital there's guys
living on the streets outside of the
veterans hospital but to go back to to
that 911 i mean
you almost wish that no family member or
anybody who lost anybody had to want for
anything you know emotionally totally or
with the kids and everything
but
we've been neglectful as uh
a country does it come out in the music
of it do you think does it come out in i
think
well it's funny because i'm actually
writing about this right now because
we're adapting the book into a scripted
tv series so which reminds me to ask you
for any hot tips about how to survive in
hollywood um i'm gonna need some advice
from you but uh
the
for real
yeah no i got it i got you yeah man okay
cool so we'll get to that after we
figure out who the zodiac killer was and
we take care of this 9 11 issue real
quick then we'll get to like advise me
about my career okay cool um
no it's i'm writing about i think this
having to tease this element out for the
purpose of developing scripted
characters like is
i think it made the generation that sort
of
came of age like young but not teenage
people people who are my age basically
like early 20s or thereabouts in college
even but having left the house but
you're not like a full adult yet
it made this set it imbued those
people with a sense of dread
and
kind of tragedy lurking around every
corner which i guess means the same
thing but you know that period of time
that we're talking about this era in
every human being's life where music
itself is getting in in this really deep
way and your habit your brain is having
all these reactions to the stimulation
of like being alive and being out of
your parents house and like trying to
make your own way in the world and
trying to understand
the terms of that world that you're
entering like well how does this world
function and what are its rules and to
have that completely upended
overnight in that way and to have like
all of the adults around you
panicking
and feeling like it creates this sort of
but you're still young like and you're
sort of like i mean what happened we
talked i talked about this a lot in the
book and a lot of the the artists do you
know everyone just partied harder it's
not like anyone sat around
wisely at bars being like wow i think
this has really affected our generation
no everyone is just like more drugs more
drinking more
like i was going out five nights a week
i'm gonna go out seven week you know so
it's not it's not conscious like that
but i think looking back which is my job
in this moment it's about remembering
how it you just felt like
[ __ ] this world is even more confusing
and unknowable
than it was before and i was barely
getting a handle on the world as it was
before um and then just one more thing
on that which is
it's also happening at the same time as
napster at the beginning of file sharing
like these cr obviously these crazy
technological revolution things that
changed all of our lives as we were
talking about before it's like the
beginning of camera phones and all this
we didn't have those it's unimaginable
but like 20 years ago
you know at that lcd sound system show i
didn't have anything in my hand
that i probably there was still some of
that and that was 2011. but certainly in
2001 like nobody had that
you weren't going there stroke shows at
mercury lounge and like recording you
know it just wasn't that was just not an
option it was all happening in what
field now like an incredibly preciously
anonymous time so
it was kind of a mind [ __ ]
but you know in the precious anonymous
time though you only could
be responsible for the things that you
were seeing around you you know and now
when you wake up and you spend a [ __ ]
half hour on your phone you're worrying
about all the other [ __ ] that has
nothing to do with you and people are
obsessed with things that have nothing
to do with them and then neglect the
things that
have to do with them i mean that's a
it's a powerful thing that you think
that
you know you had nothing in your hand we
used to go to shows and and i said we
told the dude we were going to meet
right here by the by the f parking lot
and then this guy walks up and you're
like hey
he [ __ ] found it not you know where
is he i've been texting him like i mean
there was something [ __ ] natural and
innocent about now about seeing somebody
on your way in and you're looking over
your shoulder and all of a sudden he's
like oh there he is right there i mean
that's not
hearing that's not here now it's not we
like i really miss it i do miss that a
lot and i was just you know totally
there was this sort of sense of wonder
about even
travel you know like well how am i going
to meet this person well we'll just have
to i'll call them at the hotel when they
get there so i mean it was just and that
would seem crazy like i'm laughing
because i'm just imagining what if you
said to someone now
so i'll meet you in that parking lot and
that i mean it would seem like so creepy
and insane it's like just text me but it
was it felt more
romantic as a cheesy word but it's kind
of a good word for it but also
if people if somebody has uh if
somebody's worrying about some about
something
and
they have a tendency to worry less about
their own business and worry more about
someone else's life you know now you're
seeing
on instagram or on probably twitter i
think is more the e has become the more
evil of of them but you know things that
would um people say about other people
that just fly in the they're it's all
approved because you can say all that
stuff to people now that you never would
you never would say it to their face you
can say it to to whatever but but
i think that um having you know a
daughter
who's 25 who went to an influencer's
birthday party
and that guy leo i mean this guy
has has a house out here
living a very lavish life that
[ __ ] started doing me on
tick-tock like he was doing impressions
of me on tick tock
and he's blown up to the point where my
own daughter went to his birthday party
in the hills and this dude's like
popping bottles of champagne and it's
like he started doing me
walking into a room and looking around
and i think he's moved on from me but
that's how this dude planted his seed
man
and like he's got good and like he's
[ __ ] wrong
[ __ ] completely
yeah it's like a
beverly hillbillies he shot up and and i
came out hey
but i mean that's how you have you know
like like cheech marine today i talked
to him on the phone i never thought
about hey let me record this you know or
or we just talked on the phone that's a
guy that i love from the time i was a
teenager and you know you call up you're
not saying hey man can you can you
facetime me so i could take a screenshot
of us it's like i would never do that
but
it's it's everywhere yeah we are like
something we are missing something yeah
yeah it doesn't feel like it did
you you were you just felt
more
i mean it's such a cliche but you you
had to you didn't have to fight to feel
present in your life in the same way
yeah um and there was these there were
these unpleasant things that allegedly
social media has solved like
you know longing wanting to know having
a crush on someone and wanting to know
what else what they're up to and like
just having to live with that as opposed
to being like i'm gonna stalk them and
all of their ex-girlfriends and
boyfriends or whatever on instagram and
in five minutes i'm going to know
everything like including where they
were last night and really do you feel
better after that like it's it's not i
mean anyway there's our there's all
these impulses that these these things
have solved or attempted to kind of like
address that i think are
you know there's like a pleasure in
having those things unsolved um but you
know i don't know now i really do sound
like an old lady
right now i made you sound like an old
lady but but when tiger woods was going
through his infidelities i uh
you know uh was always on the spectrum
of potential uh being uh he's gonna be
an adulterer an adulterer yeah that's
what i was gonna say were you doing
tiger woods i i could have
i probably could have uh
but
i was working out downstairs we had a
thing and ann when i was remembering my
wife was coming down and i could it's
pretty long thing of stairs we had a
little gym in the bottom and i grabbed
the uh directv and i tried to change the
channel but the the way the guy set the
box up i had to be at an angle and she
walked down just as the guy said you
know if your husband locks his phone i
would be concerned about what he's
hiding and she
walked in just at and she's like you
know what i want to see your phone i
said
i don't have my phone on me when i'm
working out well where is it it's
upstairs i almost stomped over her
climbing up those [ __ ] stairs
and she goes what's the code i said i
you know what is the code [ __ ]
but i mean listen i i
lived in
a bit of a double life and
there's nothing good about it and and i
think that the double life now or triple
life now
becomes
the filtered pictures the perceived life
the restaurant and the the celebration
of other things that aren't yours
and then
your life is
you compare your life to somebody who
you follow or somebody that's driving
around with stacks of money or
shoes or whatever like it's comparative
now you can compare yourself to somebody
like this as opposed to going to school
and seeing
you know me the first day i bought
nike's years ago in 1976 for forty
dollars my grandmother thought i asked
myself no i need to buy me a house true
it's also like the more that i'm showing
off on social media the less happy i am
like i notice on a direct relationship
like if you guys if the five people who
are following me on instagram notice
that i'm posting a lot you should like
you know check on me
i mean there's
being dramatic on purpose obviously but
i do think and i noticed this with my
friends too that the more you're showing
you're sort of like posturing and
peacocking about how
fabulous your life is like
even if you don't realize you're doing
it like it sounds like such an obvious
thing to say but then i just noticed in
real life like it might not even be that
i'm showing super cool like it's i mean
there's you know it's just the impulse
to kind of create an illusion that is a
reaction at least for me
to
like feeling un
happy or uneasy or just like when i'm
kind of in my life i forget to get on
instagram as much and i'll be like oh i
really need to
i i've been hosting a podcast myself and
it's like i'll be like oh i really need
to put that episode up today so people
know about you know and it'll feel like
the the good kind of obligation rather
than like
well i'm going to the farmer's market
today so i guess i'll put something up
about that and then after that i'm going
to go to you know pilates and i'll put
something up about that it's just this
sort of fake life that i'm you know
trying to pretend i have so yeah how did
you get used to the criticism girl like
you you weren't in the public eye like
like i laugh at it but it's interesting
to to read though right sure i read it
i
not one that but taken
seriously at all either pro
or con
some of them are a little more touching
to me the pro one but the con ones you
know they wish i were dead i should be
dead instead of richard and those are
mine you know
no but but you know richard ramirez has
i mean this guy how many people did he
kill 16 well we had them for 14 down
here two up san francisco
i got it right yeah
but you really don't take that serious i
find that so impressive like i i just
has anybody
has anybody done a play misty you don't
play misty for me right do you know yeah
that was that yeah
has it i think play misty for me with
social media is a [ __ ] great idea for
oh it is
i've got uh somebody now yeah and i get
a little more concerned with
uh
somebody wants to marry me
and i said sorry you know i'm already
married take it those are george also
you know so i i just don't i've i
explained to george at one time
i'm 71 years old
i've had a great life things are good
this is now i'm on the downslope and and
and i'm just having the time of my life
right now and
what are you going to tell me that i
haven't encountered either
through combat when i was in the army in
vietnam or out on the streets
nothing you say is going to bother me is
that called fishing is somebody just
looking for a reaction are they being
meaner than they normally would be
because they're just trying to get
blocked or remember when people are
trying to get blocked there was a big
deal well and i mean social media like
we not to get all eggheady but like you
we know all this from all the people the
the
leaked papers that are coming out of
facebook i mean they they are
the algorithm requires reaction and the
stronger the reaction the more valuable
the like and that's just it's really
just capitalism which is you know it's
which is fine i mean i you know it's
this isn't a sort of indictment of
capitalism necessarily but it's like
there's a sense of the purity of it
which is like the more upset you can the
easiest way to get a reaction out of
someone is to make them upset not to
make them happy like biochemically
happiness is not as strong a
a cell and you have 15 you have three
seconds to get someone's attention on
these social platforms so
in that way it's not i think it's even
if the sort of origin of it is even
before the psychology of are people
consciously trying to be mean or not and
more just that the world of social media
itself requires like the fastest most
brutal most
hardcore hardwired provocation game out
there in order to like live and succeed
um
so it's really that it's like it's in
your best interest to be as outrageous
as possible and that creates i mean
obviously that's arrested for disaster
then you know like you know that young
woman what can i say that young lady
testified on congress last week a few
days
i don't think that most of america
really understood what she was trying to
say and about what she was talking about
about the idea that facebook is in every
part of your life like it's not it's
even what the government thought they
controlled is not what it is which is
why you and i could be out there talking
about getting a barbecue
and two days later on your facebook
stuff will show up about
get a barbecue for sale and get this and
that i mean that's different than
sitting around with the newspaper and
saying oh wow you know this lawnmower is
over here
oh [ __ ] i had to go check that out and
see that yeah
all right
they're telling you they're they're
forming they're forming you however you
are however i am in our privacy of our
home everybody wants to be a leader but
then they also want to be led and i
think that yeah that's part that's part
of it to a lot of people who
unfortunately i think most of them spend
um
i think a lot of time alone
and i think that's why social is such a
big part of their lives
yeah because we've been as you are we
started out talking about we're living
through these screens you know this is
what we're doing all day and that
creates this
sense of alienation too even and so you
dig deeper into the sort of source of
that alienation which is a bit of a
perverse thing to do but yeah i mean
it's very
um
we're all in it and it's you know i mean
i we're not getting rid of it so we just
have to figure out how to how to handle
it better i guess yeah you on the screen
yeah no i know you you know you know the
the um
you know i i would go see elton john you
know i grew up listening elton john and
ellen john tell the story in there that
him and bernie thompson never wrote a
song in the same room how he would be in
one room and then that one would be in
the piano
room and then
when they brought the lyrics to your
song their first hit the thing he read
the lyrics on the paper and
he said to bernie you know things are
never going to be the same because he
could see that your song
was going to be like a hiss like these
lyrics are amazing
um
and they did it for the music do you
think and even like seeing bruce
springsteen and
rosalia and all that stuff do you think
that in that time after 9 11 that did it
still mean
as much to a songwriter to write a song
about something personal or was it more
a thing where
you might you know like if somebody has
a
a nichi song
people love it then they like be happy
then they happy like pharrell and then
they turn on it like you know everybody
likes it and then they turn on it
that's such a good question i think
well the first thing that occurs to me
to say is that like there's a lot of
different kinds of
artists right like some artists write
very personal songs and always do and so
they're they're not really like mirrors
of the time in the same way that other
artists are like
so
there's that there's sort of a super
personal songwriter types um but i do
what i the other thing that occurs to me
to say is that i think that the best art
whether you're talking about music or
what any kind of art is is a
is both universal in the sense that it
is timeless like it's evergreen it
reflects these like big themes about
being human but that it also comes at
the right moment when it's exactly what
the the world or whatever community is
respon responding to it needs but
doesn't know they need like i definitely
lived through that in meet me in the
bathroom is
you know the bands in new york in the
early 2000's that i covered in that book
are not we're never supposed to be
famous like rock and roll was dead and
we were going to do dance music now and
leather jackets were like so passe and
you know it just seemed very uncouth to
like make this kind of preening sexy
music it was like we don't do that
that's like very last century and then
there's a terrorist attack and
everyone's feeling incredibly vulnerable
and emotional and pulling together and
loving feeling connected to new york
into the legacy of cbgbz we were talking
about before and all that stuff and all
of a sudden it's like all these bands
that were making this music that
basically they were being told was not
commercial on any level and very dated
became immediately current you know like
really wild so having witnessed that
happening i think
that's part of what you that's part of
the alchemy of what you can't predict
with any art right like is it gonna hit
in the right moment is it gonna be
you know
i mean elton john has written i can
literally think of like 10 songs that
he's done this with but where it just
feels like his relationship with diana
and how he
had uh how his art and his sense of time
of the time he was living through merged
to create this sort of
moment that people are feeling what
you're feeling and it all comes together
and that's like that's what that was
that's what you can't predict that's
what makes it basically like gambling
you know it's like a business of hedge
fund management or something yeah i
don't think i don't i don't even think
even
rock people can sometimes believe their
good fortune
you know um
first of all i've known enough musicians
to know
i don't know how they make it out of
even the garage getting along i mean
there's the ego involved musically is
much more than eagles involved
comedically if you have four you think
really yeah
damn yeah okay and uh lizzy was telling
me beforehand she had something come up
for this afternoon so i won't be
respectful of your time as well
yeah i have to go soon but i feel like
we're just getting started but
you know we've been talking for a little
over an hour
man that's yeah i don't believe that it
flies by okay let's let's get to some
she's good yeah she's good
we're just getting to the important
stuff about like the meaning of life you
guys we're gonna have to do a round two
or something
right
but people follow people follow bands
and find the meaning of their life like
they stay connected to the band and they
find their listen the guy dave wilcox in
1978 had brought born to run he was like
a year younger than us to the locker
room he was playing at a track we're
like get that [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
here and he goes the boss like what
that's the boss and i didn't three years
later i'm at the sports arena the last
night of an 11-night run
we're sitting at the back and i became a
fan for life like i've met them talk to
them love them still do
and it's powerful man what
what impression a dude can make on you
the first time you see him and that's
music like you never you got a fan you
got a fan for life you know there's one
singer right now
that is not only the very contemporary
today
and i just told my wife this morning you
know i wouldn't recognize her i wouldn't
know who she was i just saw her on tv if
they didn't mention her name
and now i can't think of where she just
released a brand new olivia
i've loved every song i've heard her
saying very touching to me very
emotional
beautiful voice
but i wouldn't know her i like her music
i wouldn't know who she was and then
this one that she wouldn't know her like
if you saw her on the street you mean no
you don't guess those are the limiters
there's not a persona that you're
invested in yeah just her sound uh
that's interesting too isn't it i think
that that's that's also an interesting
fact
just just i i love her music the one
today now attorneys are saying that it's
going to lead to more divorces because
it's helping ladies that are afraid to
take that step to get a divorce this new
release is about her divorce
oh yeah and they expect to get more
business because of it it's empowering
women
and divorces that's how big she is
listen
that's a powerful that's some that's
some writing right there i probably
wouldn't hear it but i think i'm gonna
have to listen to it
oh yeah check it out yeah awesome well
thank you guys so much for having me i
feel like we didn't even talk about the
book i'm sorry we didn't even get there
you should come back sometime i wouldn't
come back again we have to have you
yeah we got to follow up on the zodiac
and we got to follow up on how many
divorces we're going to follow up with
your book
we can talk about green chile
mexico i think she thinks we're horrible
at this yes yes are you kidding me no
uh-uh
you're the one that's keeping me down
we'll take care of the magic word which
is hatch green chili like
i would literally listen to a podcast
that is only about
green chile and how to properly prepare
it and grow it
so i'm in i just roasted 50 pounds of
green chili from my house and green is
different than red so we're going to
send you something
okay we can get a free front door and
we're going to
it was a real pleasure pleasure to meet
you both and uh really thanks so much
i'll talk to you later take care bye man
we didn't even talk about i haven't even
we can keep going i mean we're still on
here we obviously wouldn't make sense to
hit the book now but uh we shouldn't man
everybody's talking about the book
i think we don't know it's a different
[ __ ] huh it was it was it didn't know it
was it was fascinating talking about
everything else yeah i really she's
really down on earth good good lady and
she's smart yeah yeah she was using
words that i've [ __ ]
but look i have to play this bag just to
hear the words again
no i'm yeah i think it
we found a little compadre there yeah
she's she's great i've got to check the
book out too um i guess all right what
else i'll do the written book because uh
i didn't get to flex on all the people i
know it yeah you brought the guitar
today with the guitar we're gonna bring
that out what are you uh what are we
gonna do working with here i'm working
with my with the [ __ ] uh
i use that every day also it's amazing
isn't it yeah i use it on my cooler
what do you want to do grant let's do
some do some voice mails yeah yeah let
me just pull some up here can we we
don't need these dudes
you'll need the headphones on for
voicemail nothing rich all right
uh and we had a little bit of uh
a little bit of follow-up from uh one of
the friends of the podcast hey uh i'm
gonna grab her voicemail but i know gail
you recently connected you think it's
hard to get rid of
that just hang around
is it hard to get rid of it yeah
i think it's like i said on saturday i
said you ever have somebody that you're
dating and finally they meet someone
else i said i never owned a boat but
it's got to be like what [ __ ] selling
your boat is like when somebody doesn't
rely on you anymore
that's it you're all like bill
all right
uh so this is a is a voicemail from one
of the the friends of the show the the
puta in training
uh
here we go
my daughter
aaron you have to switch the feed or
anything i'm playing it on mine
that's when white dudes [ __ ] up they're
like aaron do you have to switch
us we'd be like hey i can't hear nothing
that's right how's your feet how's your
feet
i got it turned on let's try it again
i'll open it
one more time
come on man
don't make us doubt you it
if you haven't doubted me already
okay gil who wins who wins the keep
messing with this yeah dodge is in the
braves doctors
we're gonna come back we're gonna take
three here
dodgers can't beat us here at home want
to go to the game
let's go okay
when's the next game the last one was
what last night
i won't be here i'm leaving right after
the show going to burbank airport going
to las vegas
reunion with some guys that used to fly
top secret missions at that time they
were top secret cross enemy lines some
guys with green beret so it's a little
little reunion oh [ __ ] hey man where
are you guys staying are you guys going
they're holding it at the orleans hotel
it's in town next this week i don't know
let me see if
i'll get you guys some tickets to go
seeing me
grant what the [ __ ] hey i don't know man
it was working a minute ago
i'm
i think
if this was [ __ ] bill come on bill
bong it would be working now
how's bill bird doing man good uh yeah
he's doing good yeah he just uh i think
performed in atlanta the same night as
one of the the dodger games
oh yeah gilbert's [ __ ] man it's awesome
dude
there's some good comedians man
not like me all [ __ ] washed up again
[ __ ]
out there
here one day
i'll bring that [ __ ] a hand cafe
there you go let's see if we can get him
he's tough to get because he doesn't um
apparently he doesn't like to speak in
english
i don't know man
what
i can play it out of i can play it out
of my speakers but it's not coming
through
the headphones aaron you guys aren't
hearing it right
no not at all aaron can you
can you help me troubleshoot
there we go i said you are aware of the
[ __ ] cardinals
[Music]
yeah didn't they fire
the the manager after like a
season or something
that's all right you know i got an old
party because it's win now or [ __ ] you
but it wasn't we used to win now you let
a guy do his job yeah
right
i mean come on man nobody just goes in
there and wins
and then if they do the guy maybe wins a
year or two and then they [ __ ] fire
him it's like
nobody gets a chance to
coach uh order on who they didn't bring
on for usc they let him go and now look
he went back there got a championship
and it's only been two years and now
they're dumping
how about that [ __ ] hey bring them back
over here how about that yeah
nobody has any time of
you know even if you lose
one or two games man they're already i
mean all these shows that
are all in our week they have to have
something to talk about
and let it be the demise of a [ __ ]
coach that is not on even on the [ __ ]
chopping block or a quarterback that's a
rookie
rookie's man back in the day if you had
a rookie quarterback or a pitcher
somebody they stayed
back there for two or three years before
they
see the light of day
and now
even teams that are bad there's a
maybe
urban myers team they go that young
quarterback they're gonna [ __ ] that guy
up rg3 they [ __ ] up
because they tried to bring him along
too fast he's out of the game
the raiders just won their last game
they won in a mile high yeah yeah and uh
matter of fact the guy that's picking me
up the airport tonight he's an old vegas
metro cop good friend of mine
and uh what time is your flight
7 45 out of four all right jet sweet x
or no
jet sweet x what's sweet x jet sweet x
you're the number flight just sweetie no
you take like a private jet but it's
like oh you can get it for a good raid
jetsuit x is the equivalent of taking a
private plane with about 15 other pesto
on a and you land in a private airport
in vegas
and if you're running late they'll wait
for you
wow you don't have to go
two hours ahead of time
that's dope
that probably costs a chingo money no
it's not don't cause money
that would have been nice i i tried to
go some other airlines you could just
show up with your weeding out sir
your [ __ ] is out isn't it
[Laughter]
well before we get into too much trouble
you guys want a voicemail
here we go
hey george it's your niece uh you call
me pip
hi theo gill hey grant grant you're like
my cute wemo that i have a hardcore
crush on but i feel really guilty about
shout out another one of you guys
awesome keep doing what you're doing she
wants to [ __ ] i had to call because
of the segment with the shaving of
gill's pubes for his procedure
oh my god george how many questions did
you have to ask
how long did you have to spend on
exactly who was holding his nuts and how
many nurses and
did they use cream how many times did
you ask did you scream i heard i think
that you asked like four or five times
you protected it it was amazing i wish
you could have seen my face that whole
i'm protective of your levels and i'm
the bad person the whole two hours i was
just like wow my jaw was just
open
i couldn't believe it that was amazing
please keep doing that thank you grant
for not editing that or
george thank you okay the part where
gill asked you if you had ever played
steven's
steakhouse
and you were like are you serious do you
know who i am george lopez i have never
laughed harder i don't remember anything
don't you realize who this stephen
steakhouse owner is
he's from sicily
he had frank sinatra play his steakhouse
you haven't put it together yet right
now played all those things together i
love
how old was he that's
he's only about 14. no are you serious
frank's not just playing steven
[ __ ] out of here as a matter of fact
the owner told me
that the only time he had more people in
stephen's steakhouse was when i was
there the biggest night he ever had was
with frank sinatra till my retirement
dinner at my retirement we put more
people he even had people eating in the
dinner side for free then just come over
and join the party when you're done
there's just that's pretty amazing man
you know what that's congratulations man
you deserve that but but frank sinatra
at steve house yes is there a picture of
him over there that's live yes
just as you walk in the door there's a
picture of him right there how did he
how did he do that
i don't know that was he knew that
his dad his dad is one that hired him
not jimmy it was jimmy's dad that hired
him
they still have broken leg of lamb over
there
what else yeah all right next time
don rickles had the best joke
he said frank sinatra saved my life one
time i was getting my ass kicked in the
alley in fact sinatra walked up and goes
that's enough
all right nice one
hey well i want to before you before i
go to the next one i want to i want to
reach out and say thank you to p.i.p
um my niece because
she was protective of my of my levels
and and that's always good
that's what it's going to be protective
of my level she was sticking up for me
that was good was funny but it was good
no but she was concerned how many times
you know i was imagining them in my mind
200. all right anyways all right here we
go have you met her yet and she's going
to come in here i think for the for the
anniversary show well we
we can i've been talking about
conversations we have somebody's in here
some like a little stage out here doing
a little chip and dale's guessing about
some chipping some old dudes from
chippendales like dudes that danced in
that time
yeah who were there when scott was
investigating the chip like 30 years ago
and get scott to come in here and arrest
him at the end
[Laughter]
scott would do it
what up boys this is ben from north
carolina just listened to the last
podcast y'all answered my question and
[ __ ] george lopez called me a poo
show putting that on my linkedin face
straight up
anyway i got a one-part question this
time for both of you you say your friend
i love it
los angeles back in the you know the 70s
and 80s did y'all ever go to the rainbow
bar and grill you know like a big time
celebrity hub and also did were there
any crimes that you had to investigate
at the rainbow bar and grill
thanks y'all man you made my [ __ ]
week that's a good question
the uh uh
but you know what the rainbow that's a
good question you know our girl was on
talk about new york um new york has a
lot of great places
but the rainbow bar and ground sunset is
still open you're right back there you
can sit out there amazing pizza amazing
rock stories family owned i might have
to go down there mario the owner uh got
to know mario no we've never had uh
i've never had to investigate anything
out of there nothing major no murders or
anything like that great stories
he talked about how he came out here you
know he was a chicago cop
he was uh he worked for a judge back
then is still alive
no he died probably about two two three
years ago yeah he did at least his wife
died before him he had opened up another
one in vegas
and uh he had the rainbow and the roxy
right next door
he had both places he was uh he was a
fascinating guy
you know the the
you know what's interesting man is i
think it might be
that might be a book on the rainbow but
the roxy
like the [ __ ] doors played the rock
seat everybody played the roxy the
whiskey too yeah like uh you know uh
wolf van halen just played there to go
up in their private room in the rocks
yeah i got to go up there it's crazy
matt robin williams did a special at the
roxy oh really uh and
what's funny is that he went into the
audience because it's small
and
you can see the stars of that time like
you know the taxi people
and different actors and actresses in
their prime at that special because he
got off the stage and went into the
audience and he was talking to people
and wow there they all were so the
rainbow and the roxy um
you know what
there hasn't been really a lot of crime
uh around over there that you would hear
of famous murders i mean it wasn't
salminio over in some apartment out
there in west la and uh but i was out of
west hollywood
do you ever go to the starwood no the
starwood was
on crescent heights in santa monica it's
a russian um
restaurant right now and that place the
star would anybody look it up
was where van halen started a lot of the
doors played the starwood a lot of the
uh
early bands in the 70s and then
they i mean if it was still there what
would it be it'd be like the rocks the
roxy and the rainbow and the whiskey are
still there thank god
but
yeah that's historical my old partner
and uh homicide bureau gilpara may rest
in peace right now so you guys were the
gills we were the guilds and he was uh
he was working patrol out there he was
walking a foot foot beat that started
raining
and the owner of the rainbow mario came
out and said what the [ __ ] you doing out
here
he says man you [ __ ] cops out here in
l.a you're stupid come on in
took a man fed him and the girl went to
be what the [ __ ] you chicago cops don't
pay for [ __ ] you i don't need your money
right now
just hey just make it easy on yourself
and then him and gil became
good friends
over the years and that's how i got into
mario going over there with gil and
meeting him matter of fact
uh gill's boy worked there uh for a
while
just helping out around the place
i've sat back in the back room when the
restaurant was packed back in the
kitchen had pizza with mario
back there that pizza is great so here's
my idea i just thought of it so the the
year anniversary of this podcast which
if we make it something about [ __ ]
back is killed no
uh with all our werewolves manscaped and
everything full
full that's gonna um that we have our
anniversary show with an audience
at steven's steakhouse aaron
you have to wear what you're wearing
right now
can they cardinals care uh what do you
think that guy go for yeah
pests
in there we'll bring some of the people
from the year
that'd be awesome wouldn't it be great
have a band play
okay
hit him up and see right where is
stevens
right at the six right at the 5 and 7
10.
city of commerce thank him you take
where the [ __ ] bullet meets the stone
if you go south five freeway you get off
on eastern and it the off ramp puts you
right there at stephen's steakhouse all
right
there you go that'll be what was it
february march
so we're talking about 100 people
i don't know how big is it
well
we put
mice from i think we had over 450 people
there okay then we'll have 449 go i
don't want to break your record
[Laughter]
he set up he set up
for that night he actually put tables up
on the stage i mean he who spoke at your
do you have a video tape of it
uh
no i have a videotape that jimmy made
for the night that he did it really it's
funny
and uh uh did we but that's did you
retire or did somebody retire i mean
what's the what's the thing with that in
fbi i think scott said i think i'm gonna
saw a thing on scott that didn't scott
say 57 year old yeah 57 and then you can
possibly like file for an extension okay
there wasn't there is no there is no
mandatory there used to be
uh about five years before about four
years before i retired it was mandatory
age 60 for everybody in law enforcement
in california but they got the law
changed and so there is no mandatory
retirement now um
is it different is it different to
let's say
if somebody asked you to retire is it
different than somebody just deciding to
retire i think so
if they're asking to retire
that's because they're saying
if you don't you're going to get fired
yeah you know they can't uh force you
into retirement where everybody resigns
now yeah coach garudan resigned gifts he
would have been fired yes you get your
choice
and that's also the age of i think
a bit of uh
if not political correctness just saving
face of somebody who had a career
because if you said
uh you could be i mean i could have been
fired from in any of my jobs but it
didn't have
uh uh
you know you just didn't get a letter of
recommendation from that place but you
could pick up in other places but now if
everything's visual and somebody gets
fired they resign and they could go on
and get another job but she said this
[ __ ] resigned he got fired for
emails that were inflammatory to race
inflammatory to women and inflammatory
to to people who were homosexual that
that dude would never work
but in
resignation he probably still shouldn't
work but in five years
i mean
there's people out there that have done
that have taken people's lives that are
working yeah i uh i went out and i told
the sheriff i'm going out because i'm at
the top of my game i'm not bitter i'm
not angry
uh it's time you know i'm just not a yes
man i can't do
the things that the department would
like me to do
and
i just wouldn't go along with okay i
think that and that's also like a good
thing like if you go in a place
and there's
i mean to be
a superhero be a crime fighter to be
somebody that's out of the box you have
to be able to think differently like if
somebody says hey you know rockford
files [ __ ] lived on the beach
the first lethal weapon like those guys
are they're they're unusual people and
if you try to make everybody the same
which i think we live in a society now
where nobody wants to upset anybody
people get upset and you want people to
live the same people live different and
people look different and [ __ ]
are making assessments on the way that
people look or the way that people
behave or where the person with the eyes
thinks that that person belongs whether
i belong here or you belong here that's
the beginning of what all this [ __ ]
that's happening all the karen's and all
the [ __ ] people that
[ __ ] are worried about whether
somebody has a permit to [ __ ] have a
barbecue at a park and then you're just
sending police officers to do that sure
they don't do that [ __ ]
i've been looking for any excuse to rat
on anybody to do anything they want
because they're just miserable and not
happy themselves i [ __ ] right oh yeah
and it's like you know
but you know like like having a girl on
man like people are living beyond
they're living in their phones and
they're living beyond their [ __ ]
means and they're not they're not
[ __ ] cool and they're not hip and if
you have to filter your [ __ ] picture
you're not what you think you are and
everybody i've done it i filtered my
[ __ ] picture
i filtered yours too come on i put it
out there i said we need a little
[ __ ] filtering yeah
my retirement i actually
when you go you know somebody will get
up there and pose a toast to your yeah
longevity you did it well i had glasses
made up shot glasses
and it said uh
gilchriot had 187 you know my day begins
when yours ends
gill
187.
and so i told jimmy
when i get up there to speak
i want you people to have trays ready
with shot glasses filled
with tequila 450 tequila shots well we
were short we only had 400 glasses
somebody didn't get any what kind of
tequila was it i don't know i didn't ask
i didn't care
and so i just said and just pour them
out there
and so i said okay now you know you got
these glasses for those who drink i said
i just want to propose a toast to you
for those of you who don't know i
haven't had a drink in a year
i said i didn't get in trouble i didn't
do anything stupid i just wanted to stop
you know maybe too much i said
so the only reason i'm here is because
of all you so this toast is for you and
if the truth be told
the undersheriff that time every time a
cop would get busted for drunk drunk
driving though because they do get
busted
he'd put out a teletype to everybody
well so-and-so embarrassed us this week
went ahead and got arrested from drunk
driving
and it just used to
it used to eat me up you know
so i said and the sheriff was sitting
right in front
i said so the truth be known i didn't
want to live give larry waldy a shot at
catching me dirty cheers
you know and so i drank my shot
it just wasn't uh and what did larry say
to you
he wasn't there
wow
he wasn't there he wasn't there his boss
was there but everybody larry would have
laughed but everybody was laughing yeah
larry would have laughed but why did
larry do why did larry feel he had to do
that because of authority like he was
the other guy he was the at that time
uh he was number two in command
so
he thought that it was
warning to everybody else hey don't get
don't drink don't drive you're gonna get
caught and you're gonna be embarrassed
yeah so named and shamed that's what he
tried to do you know and i just didn't
go along with it and so i wasn't a yes
man so i it's time for me to go you know
what that's how they could have stopped
remember they used to put people's
pictures on
in the paper or that that's how they
could have stopped put the other all
that stuff
[ __ ] out their pictures of the vehicle
for these ladies that probably business
would have went up but
that was a little like you know a little
like hello and they put them out there i
saw you picturing that paper what
they there were some small cities that
start
busting john's and then putting their
pictures out
saying they were arrested for that [ __ ]
not good
you know
i remember the days of
going to do stand up and going down
hollywood boulevard and seeing like and
sunset like to the comedy store and
seeing uh ladies of the night out there
hmm
sure
good times
what like what sort of arrows and then
the police would come you see the police
come and they'd all take off running
into their heels that was a that was fun
because they had that flashlight that
they would put on them
and they just clicked i never ran faster
in my life
all right
what else grant all right one more one
more all right so we're working on that
on that uh we're gonna redo those guild
glasses again yeah
you have any old hi guys uh gill and
george and everybody i was actually
calling um in regard to the recent show
you had regarding like having your
parents live with you
because i'm like in such a dilemma
honestly um my mom is doing really bad
what about paul
listen you know
i don't even know what's going to be
said
but
the one
i don't know if you can say latinos but
i make fun of people being put in
assistant living
it's a tough decision to to make but you
know
more people that are not latinos do it
you know i kept i left my grandmother in
her house and they stole all their [ __ ]
from her and all that stuff but but
taking people in to a situation where
it's not the best situation for them all
it is is a roof over their head and
somebody to change them and somebody to
feed them but the people in that house
aren't
[ __ ] nurses and they're not
doctors and they're
at some point
as a culture
instead of trying to
i mean it's i mean you know people have
insurance i guess i don't know who pays
for all that stuff but you know
if you bring somebody into your house
for them to just live until they die
you destroy
the people that are taking care of that
person while they pass and beyond that i
think
i think that there's better ways
to put people
who need 24-hour care than in your
living room or in the back room or
emptying out another room
it's a tough it's a tough thing because
it's not neglect it's just are you
getting the best
care
here
than you would
with some professionals but also the
mentality of having to take care of
somebody changes the whole dynamic of
the family i i i couldn't agree with you
more and there's every case is on an
individual basis
my mom
we take my mom to a daycare center so
it's like taking
a child to a babysitter
and they had crafts and my mom loved
she'd look forward to going to it take
her in the morning pick her up in the
afternoon
then all of a sudden i noticed my mom
was sad so i asked the guy over there at
the daycare center hey what's my mom
all of a sudden she's sad she's not
going along with the program too much
and he says well it's time to get your
sisters together so we can talk
and i said okay so we go down and he
says well here's the problem
she had a friend here
friend's name was manuel
and her and manny my mom used to come
home with little crafts manual to make
stuff oh wow
and
manuel
his family just moved him out to a
full-time living living
center for them
not day care anymore
he says and i really think it may be
time for your mom if she chooses to make
the leap
and i said
i don't know
i said but i'll talk to my mom
and letting everybody know right now if
she wants to she'll go
if she doesn't
we're not okay that that's simple it's
up to her so i you know what i
appreciate that because a lot of times
they'll be like hey mom i don't want to
[ __ ] go over there well guess what
you're going oh no that that i mean you
can't do that my mom who was well into
uh
alzheimer's now i told him mom mom you
want to meet
you remember your friend manuel manuel i
said mom come on it's okay
dad's been gone a long time the manual
that used to make you all the crafts ah
ccc okay
and i said mom you know he moved out and
he's living over at this full-time
living center how would you like to move
over there
with him where he's at now
and she says
yeah i think i'd like that
and then she goes i'm igo pero que paso
you see salgo in barasada if she gets
pregnant
[Laughter]
and i said mom as long as it's not
another boy because i'm the only boy
that came out of you i've got six
sisters it's another girl i don't care
and as long as he's got money for your
mukel
and so she says was vamos wow and so
she wanted to move in
unfortunately she wasn't there a full
week
before she had a episode an episode she
had a bleed in her brain we had to get
her to the hospital
so and then she never went back to the
place
and so it was uh
it was a good move she didn't suffer
this was what she wanted
she had everything there we were
constantly uh
you know you guys had respect for her
man like you know and
she had her i mean
you know my grandmother didn't want to
go to any of those things and i took her
one day and she went in there and i
still remember the look on her face was
like grandma once you give it a chance a
chance at what and just like [ __ ] man
yeah i mean
that was what she wanted she my mom was
good my mom my sisters would cringe
my mom would say before a couple years
before she got sick
you know a few years before she got sick
my daughter was probably about 14 years
old
13 14 years old and
my mom told her hey miha
has your mom told you about the birds
and the bees yet and you could tell me a
lie because i know she hasn't your mom's
not like that but i'm gonna tell you
i've had six daughters i'm gonna tell
you the birds and the bees
mija
don't you listen to those boys
they'll tell you everything they'll tell
you they love you they'll promise you
this they'll give you little gifts
but all they want is that one thing
behind they want that [ __ ] willow
oh my god keep your legs closed me huh
don't fall for that they only want one
thing do you hear me huh
[ __ ] willow don't believe those boys
so now
i think
i think we found what to write on the
glass the shot glasses of that there you
go
two years later
my mom i go down her house my wife sarah
said hey what's up with my mom because
my mom would always tell my wife first
yeah i don't i don't want to tell don't
i'm going to tell you this but don't
tell my mijo
but she knew my she was going to tell me
anyway yeah so i said what's up with my
mom you seem nervous you say
she says she's going out on a date with
a neighbor right up the street
and that neighbor is a widower
his daughters were friends with my
sisters
and so they're going out on a date i
said really she had just a dinner and i
said so mom
quebec i understand you're going out to
dinner
no no i didn't want but he said mom
relax
it's good for you to go out you've got a
life ahead of you you go out mom
i said don't worry about lasalles i'll
take care of the authors my sisters
i said you just go out and have fun
tonight mom it's just a dinner nobody's
saying anything
and my daughter looked up and says
grandma
but just remember they only want one
thing grandma oh my god that's awesome
and my mom started let's turn beat red
oh my god and she went out with it one
time and then that was it never went out
again and
she never ended up dating another man or
anything
and it was she could have it didn't you
know i wanted her to be happy
you know that i i have that in my stand
up but but uh when my grandmother was
getting older you know they revert to
like child-like behavior
and uh
the
the caretaker
said to me you know benny's uh
birthday's coming up and i mean we don't
want to do this without asking you you
know we don't want to get her a stripper
and i said what for a birthday i said
yeah go ahead so i went to the bank my
friend went to the bank and i told him i
gave
i gave her a hundred ones to deborah the
nurse and i said okay the guy's coming
tonight let me know how it is tomorrow
i'll give you a hundred ones you know
give them to my grandmother and she
could give them to the guy whatever
dancing so they took some pictures and
they sent him the next day she said oh
benny's too much and i said oh what does
she do
grab his dick or something she goes no
she gave him three dollars and she kept
i had to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
god bless you grandma wherever you are
all right thanks guys
you